Queridos amigos, amigas, en las dictaduras,
a pesar de que todo suele parecer estable
bajo el yugo amenazador del poder
absoluto y la represión policial,
frecuentemente las cosas no paran
de moverse entre bambalinas. Al fin
y al cabo esa puede ser la única
forma de sobrevivir o sobresalir.
Pues bien, Venezuela no es
una excepción. No lo ha sido,
no lo es y mientras dure el
régimen bolivariano no lo será.
De esta forma, el pasado 20 de marzo, Tareck
El Aissami, el otrora poderoso Ministro del
Petróleo y presunto narcotraficante,
según el gobierno de Estados Unidos,
presentó su renuncia en medio de algunas
investigaciones sobre corrupción.
Sí, sí, por mucho que te cueste
creerlo, este es el contexto.
[Cómo si la corrupción no formara parte de la
identidad de la mismísima revolución
bolivariana. Lo que hay que ver.]
El caso es que hablamos de una
trama en torno al oro negro
caribeño que ya ha provocado múltiples
detenciones. Hablamos, por supuesto,
de toda una enorme purga interna en las entrañas
del último resquicio del Socialismo del siglo XXI.
Pero… ¿Qué demonios está pasando dentro
del chavismo? ¿Quiénes ganan y quienes
pierden con toda esta historia? ¿Está la
revolución bolivariana crujiendo por dentro?
Pues bien, vamos a averiguarlo.
Arranquemos.
(Venezuela es un país que sobre todo tendría que
hacernos pensar en petróleo: este país se asienta
sobre unas reservas probadas de más de 300
mil millones de barriles de crudo. Para que
nos hagamos una idea, esto representa casi el
total de las reservas de Irán e Irak juntas.)
Hablamos de una inmensa riqueza
natural que ha sido administrada
por el Estado desde 1975. Ese año se decretó
la nacionalización de la industria petrolera,
bajo la gestión de la compañía Petróleos
de Venezuela Sociedad Anónima, PDVSA. Una
empresa que rápidamente se convirtió
en la gallina de los huevos de oro.
(Según datos del Banco Mundial, las
rentas petroleras han representado
históricamente cerca del 20% del
PIB venezolano. Y eso sin contar
la suma de toda la cadena de valor del
sector: esto es, la comercialización,
el transporte y el procesamiento de los derivados.
Es decir que la relevancia real del oro negro en
la economía venezolana ha sido en
las últimas décadas muy suprior.
Pues bien, ahora cerca de 50 funcionarios y
empresarios relativamente relevantes están
en prisión por una aparente investigación que
el gobierno de Nicolás Maduro ha impulsado por
sospechas de corrupción en la Superintendencia
de Criptoactivos y la Vicepresidencia de Comercio
y Suministros de PDVSA. En base a este caso,
importantes r eferentes chavistas están siendo
acusados de apropiación del patrimonio
público y hasta de traición a la patria.)
PDVSA siempre ha sido la caja de pandora de
la historia reciente de Venezuela. Ahora,
que uno de los casos más complejos para
el orden interno del chavismo estalle
dentro de esa entidad no puede parecer
una sorpresa, ¿O quizás sí? ¡Atentos!
(T1. BUROCRACIA ROTATIVA:
UNA COSTUMBRE EN EL CHAVISMO)
Estoy seguro de que todos lo
sabemos, no es un secreto,
el socialismo bolivariano fue un proyecto
personalísimo encarnado en una figura fundamental:
Hugo Chávez Frías.
De hecho, durante años, el eslogan del Partido
Socialista Unido de Venezuela fue “Somos millones,
una sola voz”, sí, la voz del comandante.
(“Chávez ya no soy yo,
Chávez es un pueblo. Chávez somos millones.
Tú también eres Chávez, mujer venezolana,
tú también eres Chávez joven venezolano,
tú también eres Chávez niño Venezolano,
tú también eres Chávez soldado venezolano [...]
Porque Chávez no soy yo, Chávez es un pueblo”.)
De esta forma, aunque la cara visible de
todo el proceso, de toda la revolución,
fue siempre Hugo Chávez, su
gabinete fue siempre muy volátil.
Hablamos de una rotación de ministerios y
funcionarios inédita no solo en la historia
del gobierno venezolano, sino prácticamente
en las de cualquier sistema presidencialista.
[Aunque mejor no lo comparemos
con el expresidente del Perú
Pedro Castillo. Ya sabéis, todo se puede superar.]
El caso es que los gobiernos de Chávez fueron
terriblemente movidos. Fijaos en esta tabla.
Si nos fijamos en ministerios clave,
como el de producción o salud,
veremos que a duras penas los ministros
duraban más de dos años en el cargo.
Y, ojo, porque ocurría exactamente lo mismo
incluso en lo que respecta a la Vicepresidencia,
un cargo que en Venezuela es designado
por el propio presidente. Fijaos.
8 vicepresidentes en poco más de 13 años,
no me digáis que no estuvo movida la cosa.
La media por cada uno fue de 19 meses.
En cierta forma, cualquier alto cargo
revolucionario era prescindible, excepto,
por supuesto, el propio Hugo Chávez…
Aunque también había algo más que era
sagrado. Me estoy refiriendo claro está a
la gallina de los huevos de oro. Atentos.
(El Ministerio de Petróleo y Minería solo
sufrió tres cambios durante todo el gobierno
de Hugo Chávez. Aunque en realidad tras el paro
petrolero que sufrió el país entre 2002 y 2003,
como consecuencia de la resistencia de
los trabajadores de PDVSA a las políticas
chavistas, el titular de la entidad ya no cambió:
Rafael Ramírez fue el conductor de la industria
petrolera venezolana durante todo ese tiempo,
primero como Ministro del área desde junio
de 2002, y luego como presidente de PDVSA
desde noviembre de 2004. Se hizo cargo
de ambas responsabilidades hasta 2014,
poco después del fallecimiento de Hugo Chávez.)
(“El ministro Rafael Ramírez, estoy
obligado a salir en su defensa,
es un venezolano a carta cabal, un hombre
honesto, un trabajador incansable. Tiene
10 años al frente del ministerio. Ha
cumplido infinidad de tareas con una
gran eficiencia al frente de una tarea
nada fácil, enfrentando conspiraciones,
sabotajes, etcétera”. Hugo Chavez, a finales de
2012 después de ganar su tercera reelección.)
(Nosotros siempre hemos creído, lo hemos
dicho públicamente, Rafael Ramírez ha sido
uno de los baluartes de esta revolución, leal
al comandante Chávez. Diosdado Cabello en 2016)
Ahora bien, si todos los ministros
del chavismo iban y venían,
¿por qué no ocurrió lo mismo con el
responsable del sector petrolero?
Pues básicamente porque revolucionario
o no, el dinero es lo primero.
Y es que fijaos, de acuerdo con cálculos
del economista venezolano Francisco Monaldi,
profesor-investigador del Instituto Baker de
Políticas Públicas de la Universidad Rice en
Houston, a partir de los datos sobre la
Balanza de Pagos reportados por el Banco
Central de Venezuela (BCV) durante el período
2004-2014, el país caribeño facturó en dicho
período de tiempo un millón de millones de
dólares, esto: un billón de dólares hispano.
Una cifra exorbitante difícil de dimensionar:
digamos, por poner un ejemplo, que con todo
este dinero se podría pagar la deuda argentina
con el FMI unas veintidós veces. ¡De locos!
Hablamos, por tanto, de una inmensa fortuna… Que
fue utilizada - por no decir dilapidada - por el
chavismo, entre otras cosas, para financiar todo
su plan de nacionalización de las industrias
básicas. Durante esos años el gobierno venezolano
compró por la fuerza decenas y decenas de plantas
y entidades productivas privadas, así como
Bancos, o cadenas de supermercados, de todo.
Por supuesto, estos ingentes fondos fueron
también claves para desarrollar las grotescas
redes de clientelismo que el chavismo
puso en marcha a fin de asegurarse un
amplio respaldo electoral con
fondos públicos. ¿Queréis una
prueba? Pues prestad atención:
(Chávez; Los precios dime:
“Fíjese usted en el mercado capitalista
está en un aproximado de 1.899 bolívares.
En la revolución, en el socialismo está en 1.123.
Chávez: No, ese no es. No te digo, vamos a
borrar. Ponle el Super-Chávez: 857 bolívares va
a costar esto. Es un ahorro de 55%, menos de la
mitad de precio”.Hugo Chavez en 2011, lanzando
un plan de electrodomésticos subsidiados.)
Naturalmente, todas las mieles de la revolución
dependían de una sola cosa: que PDVSA funcionara
y lograra facturar todo el dinero que el proyecto
chavista necesitaba. No se podía jugar con fuego,
la estabilidad aquí era clave, no sea que el
flujo de dinero se interrumpiera. Y por eso
no hubo prácticamente cambios... Claro que
eso con Nicolás Maduro ha cambiado y mucho.
LA CAÍDA DEL MURO DE CONTENCIÓN)
En marzo del año 2013, días después del
fallecimiento de Hugo Chávez, Diosdado Cabello
lanzó un mensaje particularmente inquietante:
(“Porque Chávez era el muro de contención de
muchas ideas locas de esas que se nos ocurren a
nosotros. Y el presidente imponía su liderazgo,
su prudencia y su conciencia y nos
evitaba actuar en muchas ocasiones”)
Es decir, que aunque pueda
sorprendernos ahora resulta
Chávez era el moderado… ¡Pues vaya moderado!
El caso es que si leemos entre líneas y
analizamos los sucesos posteriores a la
muerte del líder chavista, podemos ver que este
tipo de mensajes desafiantes no se dirigen hacia
la disidencia o la oposición política, si no sobre
todo hacia el mismo chavismo. Un movimiento que
experimentó una especie de balcanización una
vez que desapareció ese “muro de contención”.
(En abril de 2013 cuando Nicolás Maduro ganó
los comicios posteriores a la muerte de Chávez,
por supuesto con múltiples
irregularidades de todo tipo,
el chavismo se fragmentó en varias facciones:
Una liderada por el propio Nicolás Maduro,
la cual supondría de alguna manera la
continuidad ideológica de Hugo Chávez.
Una capitaneada por Jorge
Arreaza, entonces Canciller,
que representaba a la familia de Hugo Chávez.
Una liderada por Diosdado Cabello, a quien se
señala como un radical dentro del chavismo,
crítico de la supuesta “moderación”
de Maduro con ciertos temas.
Y otra vinculada con las FFAA,
y pilotada por altos cargos
uniformados que estaban también
al frente de industrias básicas)
Naturalmente, había otros muchos caudillos de
rango medio que poco a poco fueron integrándose
en las diferentes facciones y provocando muchos
cambios. Por ejemplo, la familia de Hugo Chávez
fue perdiendo poder e influencia, mientras
que en paralelo Jorge y Delcy Rodríguez,
hoy presidente del parlamento y vicepresidenta
respectivamente, fueron tomando fuerza.
En cierta forma, solo las Fuerzas Armadas
y Nicolás Maduro lograron fortalecer su
posición. Y a medida que este último
ganaba terreno iba expulsando a sus
propios disidentes dentro de la Revolución. Esto
ocurrió incluso con los pesos pesados. Fijaos.
N1(12 de diciembre de 2017: La Fiscalía venezolana
investiga a Rafael Ramírez por corrupción en
PDVSA . El exministro de Energía y Petróleo,
predilecto del Gobierno de Hugo Chávez, es
indagado por su posible responsabilidad en
"operaciones de intermediación" en
la compra y venta de crudo. El País)
N2(13 de marzo de 2018: Miguel Rodríguez Torres,
el exministro del Interior de Venezuela arrestado
por "conjuras y complots" contra el ejército.
Funcionarios del Servicio Bolivariano de
Inteligencia Nacional (Sebin) detuvieron
el martes en Caracas al exministro del
Interior Miguel Rodríguez Torres. BBC)
N3(25 de noviembre de 2021: Exfiscal
general de Venezuela, Luisa Ortega,
pide asilo en España. La ex fiscal general Luisa
Ortega Díaz, crítica del régimen venezolano,
destituida en 2017 y refugiada en Colombia,
pidió asilo político en España. DW)
Ya lo veis, purgas en toda regla. Purgas
de antiguos líderes y colaboradores del
gobierno chavista que de repente, en un momento u
otro, dejaron de encajar en la visión de Nicolás
Maduro. Y como ocurre en todas las dictaduras,
eso equivale a la persecución política y policial.
Al final, Diosdado Cabello se terminó alineando
con Nicolás Maduro, y el régimen venezolano
quedó compuesto por una especie matriz bipolar
interna, donde civiles como Maduro, Cabello o
los Rodríguez, por un lado, y los militares, por
otro, acordaron sostener conjuntamente el poder.
Es decir, la balcanización que se
produjo tras la desaparición de Chávez,
terminó provocando la reconfiguración
del movimiento socialista y no el
desmoronamiento del régimen. Había que
salvar los privilegios a toda costa.
Pero… Volvamos al punto clave: ¿Qué ocurrió
en todo este tiempo con PVDSA? ¿Qué ha pasado
para que en marzo de 2023 se desate una
nueva purga del chavismo a gran escala?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
(T3
EL FIN DE LA VENEZUELA SAUDITA)
A pesar de que no es una frase verificada,
se dice que John D. Rockefeller pensaba que
el mejor negocio del mundo era una
empresa petrolera y que el segundo
mejor era una petrolera mal administrada.
Con todo y eso, la pésima administración de
PDVSA ha provocado la histórica debacle de la que
fuera una de las economías petroleras más sólidas
del mundo, un país que ahora está a la cola de
producción y riqueza en el ranking de la OPEP.
El desastre ha sido tan grande que si
allá por los años 2012 y 2013 el país
exportaba crudo por unos 100 mil millones
de dólares anuales y el gobierno recibía
más de 60 mil, hoy los números son tan
pobres como estos. Fijaos y comparad.
N4(18 de noviembre de 2022: Los ingresos
petroleros de Venezuela rondan los 3.500 millones
de dólares, según Maduro. La producción petrolera,
que llegó a ser de 3,2 millones de barriles
diarios en 2002, se desplomó a niveles históricos
en 2020 cuando toco su punto más bajo en décadas:
400.000 bd, un retroceso a niveles de 1934.
Actualmente, ronda los 700.000 bd. Swissinfo)
Terrible. La gallina de los huevos
de oro desapareció por completo.
Y es que, a pesar de que los rendimientos de PDVSA
estaban en franco retroceso desde el año 2010,
el golpe de gracia vino en 2019 con las sanciones
impuestas por Estados Unidos. Desde entonces el
régimen bolivariano para saltarse las sanciones
tiene que triangular la venta de crudo con un
sinfín de idas y vueltas que por supuesto
terminan siendo de todo menos transparentes,
¡y es allí donde justo estalló la
purga chavista! Prestad mucha atención.
(T4. CRIPTO CORRUPCIÓN SOCIALISTA)
Desde al menos 5 años, el crudo venezolano ha
tenido que comercializarse mediante intermediarios
chinos, indios y rusos, generalmente usando
criptomonedas que permitan esconder el
cobro de los ingresos. Es por eso que las
investigaciones de la fiscalía chavista se
iniciaron en torno a la Superintendencia
de Criptoactivos y la Vicepresidencia de
Comercio y Suministros de PDVSA.
Con este circuito se ha detectado
la pérdida de cerca de USD 3.000 millones,
según el fiscal chavista, Tarek William Saab.
(“Igualmente, quiero recordar que una vez
comercializado el crudo asignado legalmente
se incumplió con los pagos correspondientes
a PDVSA. Ahí entonces es donde está el daño
patrimonial. [...] Se determinó que esta red
utilizó un conglomerado de sociedades mercantiles
para legitimar el capital obtenido de dichas
ventas por medio de adquisición de criptoactivos,
bienes muebles e inmuebles, inversiones
inmobiliarias, demostrando además un estilo de
vida que no corresponde a un funcionario público”.
Tarek William Saab, 25 de marzo de 2023 )
Es decir, el sistema fraudulento habría
funcionado mediante el cobró en criptomonedas
del crudo exportado, cuya facturación
luego no llegaba a las arcas de PDVSA,
sino que terminaban en otras cuentas
paralelas manejadas por funcionarios.
En el marco de este proceso
perdieron su puesto, entre otros:
Tareck El Aissami, quien era Ministro
de Petróleo desde abril de 2020 y había
ocupado los cargos de vicepresidente
de Nicolás Maduro entre 2017 y 2018,
y Ministro de Interior y Justicia de
Hugo Chávez entre el 2008 y el 2012.
Y Asdrúbal Chávez, el presidente de PDVSA y
primo del fallecido presidente Hugo Chávez.
Es decir, que hablamos de dos pesos
pesados. Sobre todo el del primero. Todo
un capo del régimen acusado de ser un importante
narcotraficante por Estados Unidos. Poca broma.
Ahora bien, ¿quiere decir esto que
el chavismo está ahora entrando
en una nueva era de transparencia y
responsabilidad institucional? Pues,
lógicamente no. Venezuela es, según el Atlas
de Impunidad, elaborado por Eurasia Group y
el Chicago Council on Global Affairs, uno de
los 11 países con más impunidad del mundo.
Venezuela está a la par de países como Afganistán,
Yemen, Sudan, Burundi, Chad o Congo, entre otros.
Y siento decirlo, pero eso
no parece que vaya a cambiar.
Toda esta trama, toda esta enorme purga, responde
a solo un objetivo: los intereses de Nicolás
Maduro. Pero, ¿Pero por qué ahora? ¿A quién
le convenía que todo este globo de corrupción
estallara justo ahora? ¿Por qué cargarse
a un peso pesado como Tareck El Aissami?
Pues… Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
(T5 CERRANDO FILAS EN TORNO
A LA TENTATIVA TRANSICIÓN)
Según la Constitución venezolana, en
2024 tienen que celebrarse elecciones
presidenciales. Pero como todos
sabéis, los comicios de este país
están más amañados que una partida de
póker en casa de Kim Jong-un. Y además,
el gobierno acostumbra, cuando se acerca el
calendario electoral, a inhabilitar a los
perfiles opositores que sean relativamente
competitivos para no correr ningún riesgo.
Sin embargo, 2024 llega con un contexto
algo diferente. El desgaste económico
chavista es más que evidente, pero el uso
de la fuerza facilita que se mantengan en
el poder. Pese a ello, tanto la
oposición venezolana como EE. UU.
han tratado de plantear la posibilidad
de una “salida limpia” el próximo año.
N5(29 de noviembre de 2022: Elecciones
2024: la oposición venezolana buscará
un acuerdo electoral en la nueva
fase del diálogo con el chavismo)
La idea sería concurrir a unos
comicios transparentes donde
naturalmente el chavismo perdería,
y que estos entreguen el poder sobre
la base de una amnistía que apunte a
una transición democrática pacífica.
Naturalmente, ¿Qué queréis que os diga? Todo esto
es más idealista que probable. Aunque en cierta
forma es una suculenta oferta para todos aquellos
que después de llenarse sus bolsillos ahora
quieran bajarse del barco socialista a bajo coste,
y disfrutar de los “ahorros” tranquilamente.
Sin embargo, este escenario es el que precisamente
resulta menos atractivo para las FFAA del país.
Tras el desplazamiento de Aissami, el coronel
Pedro Tellechea fue elegido para asumir el control
de la cartera petrolera. Con su ingreso al círculo
rojo, la Casa Militar ya controla los Ministerios
de Defensa, Interior, Energía Eléctrica,
Atención de las Aguas, Agricultura, Alimentación,
Desarrollo Minero, Vivienda, Transporte, Obras
Públicas y hasta el Despacho de la Presidencia.
Y por encima de todas las cosas
tenemos la joya de la corona:
la gestión petrolera en un momento en
el que Estados Unidos parece dispuesto
a aliviar ciertas tensiones para que pueda
repuntar la producción petrolera. En estas
circunstancias mejor un militar que un supuesto
narcotraficante para contentar a Washington,
¿no os parece? -Aunque no implica que el primero
no sea o segundo. Ya sabéis, la apariencia cuenta…
Sea como sea de esta forma, las únicas
ramas civiles que permanecen consolidadas
son las vinculadas al propio Nicolás
Maduro; y los hermanos Jorge y Delcy
Rodríguez, presidente del legislativo y
vicepresidenta del país respectivamente.
(Los uniformados garantizan la continuidad del
régimen. Ellos son quizás los más interesados
en que este no caiga. El poder y los
privilegios con los que viven dentro
del país no son comparables con un retiro
de la actividad pública, aunque esté lleno
de garantías de impunidad y amnistías… Que
luego habría que ver si se cumplen o no.
Digamos que los militares han conformado algo
así como una argamasa impenetrable y segura
de decenas y decenas de personajes que disfrutan
de un estatus superior y que está legitimado por
supuestos servicios a la soberanía nacional. Un
estatus que llegaría a su fin con una transición.
Sí, puede que algunos disfrutaran de las
amnistías prometidas - si es que luego se
cumplen - pero el ejército forma una especie de
piña mucho más amplia. Por eso sistemáticamente
Nicolás Maduro trata de desplazar a chavistas que
quieran salir de la cancha por militares leales,
aunque eso suponga darles más
y más poder a los uniformados.)
El chavismo puede haber, por tanto,
lanzado está “lucha anticorrupción”
para alinear sus fuerzas de
cara al futuro fraude de 2024,
aunque la oferta opositora se prepare
para presentar un candidato único.
En cualquier caso, estamos ante la última purga
bolivariana y asistiendo a lo que parece ser,
la lenta, pero firme militarización
del poder político en Venezuela,
un país donde el verde oliva avanza sobre cada
vez más y más áreas y espacios de poder. Cada
día que pasa Maduro y el destino de Venezuela
parece más entregado a las fuerzas castrenses.
Y ahí tipos como Tareck El Aissami
ya no tenían sitio. Más aún cuando su
permanencia en el gobierno suponía un
enorme desplante para Estados Unidos.
¿Lealtades en el régimen bolivariano?
Ninguna, el cheque siempre va primero.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Cuáles crees que serán las consecuencias
de esta purga petrolera en Venezuela?